ses Tamam Eee önünde Kağıt kalemi olan
kaç kişi var tabii okuldayız herkes deak
e Sağ elini kullananlar
kimler
sol sol daha sizle başlayalım Eee
isminiz Kübra isminiz Gökhan da Kübra so
den eklerim misiniz Sağ elini
kullananlar Sizin
isminiz
yok
isir
adını heralde Hepimiz öyle başlıyoruz
ben 5 yaşındaki oğlum ilk adını yazarak
Oka şy şimdi
denekler bu sefer kullanmadınız elinizde
de isminizi yazar
mısınız nasıl
oldu
zorunuz
sağ
Tara Zor Değil mi yani bize Normalde en
kolay gelen şey bile birisi size öyle
yapma böyle yap deyince Yani siz siz
olmayınca başkasının dediğini yapınca
Aslında çok zor
olabiliyor bu çok basit gözüken yaklaşık
20 sene önce benzer bir denek olarak
Maruz kaldım bir sosyal deneyin bir
parçasıydı ve aklımda kalıcı bir mesaj
bıraktı mesaj da şu hepimiz kendimize
özel bireyler en basit en temel
şeylerimiz bir tanesi bir kalemi nasıl
tuttuğumuz angelim de tuttuğumuz ve
hepimizin farklı stilleri var Farklı
Yolları var E farklı meşrepleri var ve
hepimizin de başarıya gitmesinde Eee bu
meşrep kullanması Bu yolu kullanması
birinci öncelik
Eee şimdi hemen giriş yapmış gibi Olum
öncelikle buraya beni davet eden Eee
başta organizasyon komitesi ve de bu
organizasyon komitesine bu vizyonu veren
Eee bu okulun öğretmenlerine Çok
teşekkür ederim Eee kendi öğrencilik
yıllarıma gittiğim zaman çok iyi
liselerde üniversitelerde okumama rağmen
Eee Belki de öğrenci tanımının kalıbı
sebebiyle bu tip ortamlar bizim
zamanımızda yoktu o yüzden çok çok
teşekkürler geleceğimizin emin ellerde
olduğunun Eee çok önemli bir işareti
Eee bugün girişimcilik üzerine konuşmak
üzere karşınızdayım E bir girişimcinin
girişimcilik üzerine konuşması çok
tehlikeli y bir gün çok iyi gidebilir
Her şey bir sene sonra karşınıza geçip
bu girişimler nasıl iyi gitmedi de
konuşabilirim Eee ama Eee şimdi
Eee Bu bir yol bu hiçbir zaman tek bir
duraklı Bir şey değil bir tren yolu gibi
düşünün Eee her zaman farklı duraklar
olacak iyi duraklar kötü duraklar Eee
ama sonunda gideceğimiz yoldan zevk
alıyorsak bu başarılı bir yol Eee 7 adım
benim İngiltere'de geliştirdiğim bir
model
Eee benzer bir konuşma ortamında 2
saatlik bir zaman ayrılmıştı bana bir
müşterime sunum yaparken müşterimin
CEO'su kulağ böyle tam sunumdan önce
yanaşıp Murat 15 dakikam var dedi ben
böyle 2 saatlik sunum hazırlamış şım Ne
yapayım ne edeyim Ayak üstü 7i tane şey
yazdım bu yi şeyi söyleyeceğim Bu yedi
şey onların kafasına kalacak diye Ondan
sonra da yaptığım sunumların birçoğunda
artık yi adım metodunu kullanmaya
başladım bugün de 7 adımda girişimciliği
anlatacağım ama girişimcilik öyle bir
şey ki teoride anlatmanız hiçbir anlamı
yok Çünkü herkesin demin gördüğünüz gibi
bireysel yolculuğu O yüzden aslında ben
size bireysel yolculuğumu anlatacağım
zaman zaman çok sıkıcı gelebilecek zaman
zaman çok sürüel gelebilecek Allah bir
zaman kıstım var sağdan soldan
durdururum çok fazla sıkıcı olursa ama
benim için çok eğlenceli Umarım siz de
eğleneceksiniz yanlış bir şeye Ben de
basabilirim kendi yolculuğumuz Biraz
önce yaptığım örnek Muhtemelen 30 sene
40 sene 50 sene Allah uzun ömür versin
sonuna kadar aklınızda kalacak örnekti
hepimizin yolculuğu kendi yolculuğumuz
ne Bill Gates'in ne Steve
jobs'ın ne de işte Türkiye'de örneğini
gördüğümüz birçok başarılı girişimcinin
yolu kendi yolculuğumuz ile onlar
yolculuğu yani dergilerde okuduğumuz
kitaplarda okuduğumuz yolculuklara
baktığımız zaman tabii ki kendimize
feyaz alacağımız şeyler var ama Birinci
Adım Ben geçtiğimiz işte 3738 yılıma
baktığım zaman aklı başında olduğum
yıllara baktığım zaman bir numaralı bir
numaralı önemli şey benim için kendi
yolculuğumu çizdiğim andır hayatımdaki
önemli kırılma anlarından bir tanesidir
birisiymiş gibi bir yola girmektense
birisinin istediği Okulu seçmekten Eee
birisinin istediği derse gitmektense
birisinin istediği kod pantolonu
giymekten kendim bunu beğendim bunu
istedim bunu yapıyorum bu bu sebeplerden
yapıyorum tutturmam amaçlı bu bu
sebeplerden yapıyorum sonuçları bu
olabilir değerlendirmesi yoluna
girdikten sonra
oldu her şey İzmir'de 1978 yılının
gerçek bir bahar gününde Karsız bir
bahar gününde başladı
E çok hızlı geçeceğim geri kalan kısmını
Çocukluğumda en çok sevdiğim şeylerden
biri o zamanlar çok fazla oyuncak yoktu
bu Aslında en önemli Slayt slaytın
sonunda anlayacaksınız
plastik askerler vardı o askerlerle
oynamaktı E normal çocukların yaptığı
gibi sadece onlarla Savaş yapmazdım
futbol delisiyim bir tane böyle işte
Türkiye'de Bulunduğunuz yere göre meşe
denir bil denir onlarla bunlar arasında
futbol oynatırdım hepsinin Bir ismi
vardı E işte benim neslim Siz daha yakın
İşte en golcü oyuncunun adı dgl o zaman
Liverpool'un
kaptanıyla maç yaparken o ülkelere
giderdim kafamda yok işte Danimarka'da
Brezilya'da Arjantin'de maçlar yapardım
ona öle kendimi oradaymış gibi
hissederdim değişik bir hayal dünyasının
içindeydim 5-6 yaşından
itibaren Eee Yolculuk daha sonra aynı
Kılıç Aslan gibi benim Muhtemelen
kimliğimi en çok şekillendiren
okullardan biri olan bornov doasi attı
Beni Eee Sınavla girilen bir liseydi
bizim zamanımızın Türkiye'nin en iyi
liselerinden bu bana 7 sene Eee Aynı
arkadaş grubuyla aynı öğretmen grubuyla
bir arada olma şansını verdi gerçekten
kişiliğime çok önemli şeyler kalı eşimi
bile orada buldum öyle diyeyim ben size
E şimdi odadaki insanların bir kısmının
çok önemli bir kaygısı vardır şimdi
Anadolu sesi yıllarından üniversite
sınav yıllarına gidiyorum bu Muhtemelen
bir sınav kaygısı olacaktır e bizim
zamanımızda iki tane sınav vardı ÖSS
ÖYS hava soğukken Murat Günen çok
çalışkan ÖSS'de Türkiye derecesi yaptı
ondan sonra havalar güzelleşti İzmir'e
gitmişsiniz bilirsiniz havalar güzelken
İzmir'de yapacağınız son şey çalışmaktır
bakınız İzmir ekonomisi
e herkes yatar ben de işte o zamanda
kredili sistem vardı okulda 5 bu5 senede
bitti kocab Bahar semester boş ne yaptık
işte televizyon izledik sinemaya gittik
spor yaptık sosyal arajmanlar arkadaşlar
işte herkesin Türkiye derecesi yaptı
kesin Boğaziçi bir ligde kazanacak dedi
Murat pıt 9 Eylül İngilizce işletmeye
zor girdi
Şimdi o zaman baktığım zaman o zaman
bakıldığı zaman yani ya çok yandı bitti
kü oldu bu çocuk Çünkü 3 saatlik bir
sınav ki siz de bu tip sınavlara
giriyorsunuz devamlı hayatınızın
tamamını belirliyor izlenimine sokuyor
Kesinlikle böyle dil olduğunu Bugün 20
küsür sene sonra arkama baktığım zaman
görebiliyorum yani o gün kötü gözüken
bir şey aslında başka şeylere hayr
Alamet olabiliyor aklınıza
getiremeyeceğin arkadaşlarınızın ailin
teskin ettiği ya vardır bunda bir hayır
dediği bir sürü şey geçiyordur başınıza
Siz de diyorsunuz ki yok Arkadaş bunda
hayır yok bu kötü değil yani gerçek E
biraz önceki hocamın değerli hocamın
anlattığı gibi hepimiz kendine has
kendine müasir insanlarız kendi DNA
yapılarımız var Kendi yollarımız kendi
kaderlerimiz kendi düşüncelerimiz var
Eee 9 Eylül de benim için öyle oldu bana
da 9 Eylül ne verdi yine girişimcilik
konusunun içerisinde bunlar hep vardır
istediğimi yapma istediğimi hayal etme
yetisi verdi
Eee çok değerli Öğretmenlerle tanıştım
çok değerli projelere dahil oldum biraz
da
işletmede olduğu için nispeten rahattı
Yani bir mühendislik bir doktorluk gibi
değil bir hukuk gibi değil bölüm olarak
Uluslararası bir öğrenci organizasyonu
olan ıac adındaki bir organizasyona
girme ve vakit
harcayabilir e hayatındaki önemli
kırılma noktalarından biri de
organizasyon oldu şimdi Eylül ayında
geldiler bizim okula Ben 1 sınıftayım
tanıtım yaptılar ben dedim ki ya 3
senedir çalışıyorum Ne çalışacağım
gönüllü organizasyon yatarım ben dedim
Yani biraz İzmir'de işte Üniversite
ortamını yaşarım dedim yani doğaldır
yani bayağı bir işte Şimdiki gibi bir at
yarışı şeklinde üniversiteye
hazırlanıyorsunuz Yani en son yapmak
istediğiniz şey okul açıldı hadi gelin
şimdi şu dernekte çalışmaya devam edin
Neyse 22 Kasım 1996 tarihinde Eee şimdi
çok yakın dostlarım olan iki arkadaşı
ikna etmesiyle Murat Gel Ey çok güzel
bir parti var bu dernekte ymiş demesiyle
Eee ı'in kapısına azımızı attık partide
martida yoktu bayağı Dernek toplantısı
vardı kandırmışlar girdik dahil olduk
Eee hiç unutmadım anekdot elektrikler
kesik Eee tam böyle derneğin kapısına
girdik 7 katta Gireyim mi girmeyeyim mi
Gireyim mi girmeyeyim mi diye kafamda
şey yaptım yani 7 kat çıkılır mı en
yakın Dostumla beraberim ya Hadi murat
gidelim dedik gittik hayatımız değişti
neden hayatımız değişti Eee yine bir Eee
çok önemli Şu anda bir de hayatımın iş
hayatımın çok önemli bir unsuru olan Eee
gönüllülükle Eee var olmayan bir fikri
geliştirmekle geliştirdiğim fikrini
birine anlatmakla ilgili 5 sene boyunca
kontrollü bir ortamda deneme şansım oldu
yani bu tip konuşmaları 181 yaşında
Yapma şansım oldu İngilizce Türkçe hiç
fark etmez aklıma gelen bir fikri KK bir
Birleşmiş Milletler projesi haline
getirme girişimcilik üzerine şansım oldu
yine hayatımın kırılma noktalarından
biri oldu 1 maddeyi tekrar Bunların
hepsi topluyorum kendi hayatımızı
yaşıyoruz kendi hayatımızın içerisinde
girişimcinin bilmesi gereken kend
kendini tanıması gereken çok önemli
anlar var buem önemli anların şu anda
lise ve üniversitel önümüzdeki yani 56
sene hayatınızın Muhtemelen geri kalan
kısmını belirleyecek sizin hayatın
zorluk ve iyiliklerine karşı yönlerinizi
belirleyecek anlar
Eee Bu
resim yine üniversite yıldırımın ve da
daha sonraki yıldırımın önemli bir
imgesi hayatı hiçbir zaman bir
dalgaların içerisinde yüzen dalga
çarptığı zaman Sev işte zorlanan işte de
dalgaya takılıp devam eden gibi
düşünmemek gerekiyor hayata her zaman
bir SF tahtasının üzerinde bir sonraki
dalgayı bekler gibi beklemek gerekiyor
çünkü devamlı bir şeyler değişiyor
etrafımızda eee bir girişimci olarak da
bir bir iş adamı olarak da Eee her zaman
bu prensibi Bu resimdeki prensip
Eee hayatıma Eee
yansıtıyorum İkinci nokta esnek olmak ve
anı yakalamak esnek olmak anı
yakalamakla ilgili anlatacağım çok
anekdot var
yine üniversite yıllarındaki
Hayallerinden bir tanesi yaşım kadar
ülke gezmekte Şimdi mesela 3738
yaşındayım daha fazla ülke Gezmiş değim
var böyle bir hayalim oluşturdum Hayat
böyle devam ediyor yapım çok eğlenceli
hepimiz
Eee biraz işin suyunu kaçırdım ama bunu
farklı ülkelerde yaşamaya da götürdük
dah yurt dışına gittim önce Danimarka'da
yaşadım daha sonra İngiltere'ye gittim
hiçbir şekilde Yani bu fırsat
türkiye'dedir bu fırsat Danimarka'da
amerika'dır diye kendim
O noktaya odakladım İşte buradaki
sohbetten önce bir arkadaşımız soruyordu
İşte şu eğitimi almak için sadece
İngiltere mi gitmek gerekiyor yok dedim
Dünyada başka ülkelerde de bu eğitim var
gibi geniş açılı olmak esnek olmak
farklı fırsatları görmek çok çok önemli
sadece bir girişimci için değil her
insan için çok önemli Bazen hiç
ummadığınız bir açıdan baktığınız zaman
hiç ummadığınız fırsatları
yakalayabiliyor musunuz eee bir
seneliğine gittiğim stajer olarak
gittiğim ıbm'de Biraz önceki tanıtımda
da söyle dendi bir cun
Eee executive Asistanı olarak
başladığında da yine ani yakaladığım
pozisyonlardan hiçbir şekilde kurumsal
finanstan IBM gibi bir şirkete girmek
istemiyordum yani kafamda hep böyle işte
Danışman olayım o zaman işte Biraz
önceki hocamın da dediği gibi moda işi
şirkete gir Danışman ol işte yabancı bir
Amerikan şirketine ya da Finans okutu
isan denetimci ol çünkü işte başarı ve
para o o
alanlardayız en önemli şirketlerinden
bir tanesi gideyim dedim bir Senine
gittim ve gerçekten de çok önemli
bilgiler geldi yani Hem çalışma olarak
hem network
olarak yine aynı mesajı Biraz önceki
mesajı tekrar vereceğim Kafamızda
hedefler koymak çok önemli ama bazen
bazı fırsatlar geliyor O hedeflerin %
isini tutturuyor geri kalan % isini
tutturmak için o hedefin o fırsatını
yakalamak yeterli oluyor E bugün ben
Finans yapmak istemiyorum diye ıvm gibiş
şirketi Redd etseydim orada 10 küsür
sene çalışma
ses üst düzey seviyeye
gelmezdim Biraz sonra geçeceğim
girişimci kerki gezdim İngiltere'de
yaşadığım renkli Hayat yaşamazdım
bugünki karşınızda olmazdım Neden ya ben
Finans yapmak istemiyorum parantez iç
şımarıklığı yapsaydım O zaman ne yapmak
lazım Hayat her zaman % biz
istediklerimizi vermi Çünkü
istediklerimiz her zaman % doğru değil
bazen olaya farklı açılardan bakmak
gerekiyor aramızda anneleri babaları
büyükleri de görüyorum bazen TEB Dinek
gerekiyor farklı bakış aısı için
e değişik bir hanım vardır baktılar ki
ben çok konuşuyorum ya Murat sen sadece
rakamla uğraşma daha çok insanlarla
iletişimde olacağım bölümde ol dediler
tamam dedim O zaman en çok konuşacağım
yere gideyim dedim neresi dediler satış
yapmak istiyorum dedim dediler ki Tamam
çok güzel İngilizce konuşuyorsun ama
satmak için çok İngilizce konuşmak
gerekiyor y aksanım var Gayet güzel
İzmir İngilizcesi
var hala da öyle kaç sene
geçti E şimdi dedim ki yok yapacağım ben
bu işi Müdürüm engell demeye çalıştı yok
dedim yapacağım uluslararası olarak
ıbm'in seçtiği bir ekibin oluşturduğu
bir satış şeyi vardır Akademisi vardır o
şeye girdik tök özleye gidiyoruz tök
özleye gidiyoruz Biraz önce yaptığımız o
sol el sağ el şeyini eğitimin 1 ayındaki
hocamız yaptırdı o zamana kadar çok kötü
giden eğitim çünkü ben birisi gibi
olmaya çalışıyorum yani bakıyorum böyle
çok güzel satış yapan insanları
görüyorum onlar gibi olmaya çalışıyorum
Bir an ya Murat Ya tamam yapma kendini
ol sen ayağa kalkıp konuşmaya başladığın
zaman Yanaklar kızarıyor bu kötü bir şey
değil utandığın anlamına gelmiyor
tersine karşıdaki insanlar ya adamın
yanakları kızarıyor ne kadar komik
diyebilir fazladan güvenebilir Ya bunlar
pozitif şeyler aksanı var aksanın daha
da kötüleşir gerekiyorsa pazarlığa
girdiği zaman ya Ben Türküm deyip karşı
tarafın beklemediği kontralar yap gibi
kendim olmaya yönelik esnek olmaya
yönelik adaptasyon teknikleri
geliştirdim ve Okulu
bitird Eee daha sonraki satış sürecine
girdik çok çok güzel sonuçlar elde ettik
Yani Maddi manevi Güzel sonuçlar elde
ettim birçok kete birçok yüksek
tutturmadan getirdiği özel ödüler aldık
Daha sonra 2008 senesinde dünyaya bir
ekonomik Buhran sardı bir Finans krizi
başladı E benim hayatım biraz böyle film
gibi şimdi Londra'da İnşallah gidersiniz
çok güzel bir şehirdi Finans bankalara
satış yapıyorum Eee metronun çıkışı tam
reuters dünyanın en büyük haber
ajansının karşısındadır bankalar
bölgesinde Tam ben çıkıyorum böyle
Bilgisayarım çok güzel bir gün reuters
binasını gdim banka krizi lehman Bankası
battı diye gidiyorum Yok olmaz falan
diyorum yani dünyanın en büyük
bankalarından bir tanesi çıktık kafayı
sola çevirdim or Lehın gökten var
gerçekten kutularla insanlar
gidiyor Şimdi bir şey satıyorsunuz
teknoloji genelde olsa da olur olmasa da
olur Dünyanın her yerinde bankalara
satıyorsunuz kır çıkmış batıyor filan
ben dükü o taraf kapalı mı açık mı ha
açık Tamam bardağın yarısı dolu Neyse
2008 senesinde O buhranı içerisinde
Hayatımda yaptığım en büyük satış
rakamını yaptım çünkü bazen kriz olarak
gözüken şeyler
eee Yüreğiniz atıyorsa beyniniz
çalışıyorsa sevenleriniz varsa kafanızda
netse çok büyük fırsatlara dönüşebilir
Eee ve o seney o uzun hikaye yani bu
toplantıda anlatılamayacak kad Uzun
Hikaye stratejimizi değiştirerek bakış
açımızı değiştirerek müşterilerimizi
daha iyi tanıyarak
tamus 2009
senes ama bir şe yani
şimdi
mavi ama beyaz yakalı bir iş
işte IBM gibi büyük Amerikan İngiliz
şirketlerinde ya da Boydak gibi Ülker
gibi büyük Türk şirketlerinde KÇ gibi
büyük Türk şirketlerinde yönetici
olmak yaptım yaptım ama herkes için
farklı Herkes farklı bir şey eksik dedim
kendim bir şey başlatım zaman o 3 alan
ve de çalışırken çalıştığım alanla
çakışmayan bir yerde iş kurmaya karar
verdim en kolay yapacağım şeyin de o
zamanki ortağım şimdiki Ortağım o
zamanki yakın Dostumla beraber Aşkımız
Spor alanay spor alanında bir şey
başlatalım
dedik üzerlerinde konuşacağım bir gün
Türk İngiliz İş Adamları Derneği üyesi
bir Yemekteyiz şimdiki Cumhurbaşkanımız
O zamanki Başbakanımız İngiltere'ye
gelmiş İngiliz hükümetiyle beraber
toplantılar işte iki ülke arasındaki
strateji konuşmalar falan oluyor İngiliz
bakan çıktı konuşmaya başladı futbol
üzer şakalar yapm başl şey böyle jeton
böyle vop diye düştü sesini de duydum O
sırada İngiltere'de oynayan ve de çok
güzel goller atan işte Türkiye milli
takımı o zaman kaptanı Tuncay hakkında
hiç konuşmadı Ben ble peçeteyi çevirdim
neden konuşmadım fal bir şeyler
karaladım iş adamı satışçı pazarlamacı
falan onların üzerine
yapıyorum Murat'ı Aradım işte şimdiki
ortaa Murat dedim böyle böyle bir şey
oldu ya dedim bizim milli takım kaptanı
Burada oynuyor bakan çıktı konuşma yaptı
bir kere adından bahsetmedi dedim bir
şey mi eksik acaba
p bı
bir spor
p hepimizden gel
Yek konuak istiyor
K bir önki
baş
%
[Müzik]
bir y abi kardeş gibiyiz çok yakın
birimiz var anlattık hiç yaptınız mı
bunu arkadaşlar dedi Murat bakt yok
yapmadık ama biz iş adamıyız dedik yani
sonuçta y Ben teknoloji satıyorum
arkadaşım para satıyor sonu ticari
bilgimiz var pazarlama bilgimiz var
modelde bu yani ulusları model ayağa ktı
Biz de Ağa kalktık elini uzattı en kötü
arkadaş oluruz dedi işe
başladık g y anlatsan inanılm bir şey
ger vardır doğ
oradan başladı sonra dedik ki ya işin
kulüp tarafı var birkaç hafta önce
yenilenen sağ taraftaki şeyi
görüyorsunuz ünlü bir Türk markamız
Tekstil markamız gitti Liverpool'a
sponsor oldu Onu da biz yaptık Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti Turizm Bakanlığı Liverpool
sponsor oldu Onu da biz yaptık y bir
anda böyle domine etkisi ve her
şey girişimde bulunup harekete geçmekle
başladı Yani başka kişilerin kenarda
otur ya Keşke şöyle yapsaydık dediği
birka
ğ bir şe oyuncak vardır
musun enı ad bir Günar
kıı
girim diyorum bazen Deniz çok dalgalı o
dalgalı denizde bile Sizi ayakta tutan
şey çok çalışmak e olmazsa
olmaz ve sadece bir alanda değil farklı
alanlarda çalışmak Çok önemli çünkü
teknoloji araki ortam volkanı dediği
gibi çalışmadan oturarak kazanan tek şey
tavuk Arkadaşlar onu bile kesen var yani
O yüzden çalışmak çalışmak çalışmak çok
önemli yine tavuk örneği
kullanılabilir mutlaka bir yerlerde olun
e Network yapın birileriyle tanışın
birileriyle konuşun hayallerinizi
paylaşın kimi zaman imkansız gözüken
hayalinizin gerçeğe gelmesi için kimin
Yardımcı olacağını bilemezsiniz yani
Bilfiil örneğini Biraz önce anlattım
spor konusunda hiç alakamız yokken
yaptığımız
başarı düşünmek çok önemli düşünmek
kendi içerisinde bir zaten bir mucize
yani düş kelimesi var Hayal etmekle
başlıyor düşünüyorsunuz fikir sahibi
olmak hemen arkasındaki meor bugün işte
moda deyimiyle tweet eden çok insan var
hayatta Yani sosyal medyadaki gibi
başkasının düşüncesini paylaşan kendi
düşüncelerimizi gerçekleştirelim be
yiyorsak beğendiğimizi söyleyelim
beğenmiyorsa beğenmediğimiz Söyleyelim
bir girişim için en önemli şey Özgün
olmak katma değer yapmak düşünmek
düşündüğünü yapmak o noktada Şu anda
benim burada olma sebeplerimden biri
olan Türkiye'de olma sebeplerinden biri
olan hologram işine Gelecek olursak IBM
sonra beni duygusal sebeplerden geri
çağırdı E ben de yine duygusal
sebeplerden geri döndüm oraka
eee öbür tarafta öbür işim devam ediyor
ama çok daha farklı bir görev verdiler y
pozisyon olarak işte 2 milyar dolara
yakın cirosu olan medya ve Telekom
sektörün yönetimi verdiler Bulut Bilişim
üzerine onda çalışıyoruz yine böyle
güzel İzmir Aksa hanımla konuşmalar
yapmamı istiyorlar ıbm'in vizyonu nereye
gidiyor IBM nereye gidiyor işte Akıllı
Şehirliler büyük veri üzerine konuşmalar
yapıyoruz böyle bir konuşmadan sonra
birisi geldi yanıma işte Murat Bey dedi
bizim bir projeniz var sosyal bir proje
IBM gibi bir ortağa ihtiyacımız var
nedir Proje işte aile konusunda işte
evlerde uzaktan öğretimle e ail
özellikle genç ailelere eğitim vermek
istiyorlar işte çocuk bakımı ilk yardım
gibi Var mısınız varız dedim yani Hadi
had başlayalım başladık proje bir proje
toplantısı sırasında sormaktan çok
hoşlandığım bir soruyu sordum Bu
projenin arkasına sınırsız kaynak versek
ne yapmak istersiniz oradan birisi demez
mi hram yap Ben dedim ki ya hram Yıldız
savaşlara var arkadaş Yani ben hologram
yapmıyorsam hiç kimse yapmıyor dedim O
da dedi ki yok yok dedi bir tane İngiliz
şirket var dünyadaki tüm patentlerde
bunlardı Tamam dedik bir hafta sonra
Aldı Götürdü bizi tüm proje takımını
gittik oturduk izledik hayatımdaki
önemli kırılma noktalarından biriydi e
izledikten sonra işte Hoş be sohbet
aşağı indik İki taksiye bineceğiz Ben
dedim ki bir şey unuttum baktılar böyle
bana tamam katıl bize sonra iki taksi
gitti Ben yukarı çıktım Beyler dedim
yatırım yapmak istiyorum
eee
isı
verdim dünyanın en büyük hram şirketi
olan yatırımımı yaptım işte bu Michael
Jackson sahney çık öldükten sonra 400
400 fazla uluslararası markada çalışmış
bir markaya Türk
yatırımcı komik hikayes ama gerçek
hikayesidir
şimdi bağlamak gerekirse girişim bir yol
yani gönüllülüğü denedim ve gönülü
var Beyaz yakalığı denedim Çok zevk
aldım çok şey öğrendim şimdi girişimci
biraz da Türk tip bir girişimiz Nobel
Ödülü alan Muhammet Yunus'un bir lafı
vardır mikr kredileri geliştiren
şirketlerin tek amacı ksa insanlığın da
tek amacı nefes almaktır diye Bence
şirketlerin tek amacı kar değil
İnsanların tek amacı nefes almak değil o
yüzden Türk tipi girişimci örneği olmaya
çalışıyorum hem ticaretimi yapıyorum Hem
eğitim ve sosyal sorumluluk olarak
yaptığımız yatırım mes eğitim
uygulamaları üzerine çok kafa
patlatıyoruz Türkiye'de aynı zamanda
sanata çok destek veriyoruz çünkü
biliyorum ki ben 3738 yaşında hala bir
şey kızdığım zaman kaleme alıyorsam
sizin nesildeki birçok insan bunu
dijital ortamda kullanıyor o yüzden de
biz hologramı artık dijital ortam yani
sanatlara da açmış durumdayız işte
kemper İstanbul'a katıldık iki tane
artis de çini sergisi açtık şimdi hat
sergisi açıyoruz yani teknolojiyi
hayatın her alanına koymak bizim gibi
ülkelerden gelen girişimciler için çok
çok önemli Onun da Bayrakçı
sonarlar eğlenmem laım zevk almat ha zor
Heli girişimiz ayı anda bir sürü şey
yapıyorsunuz mutlaka ve mutlaka
sevdiğiniz işi yapın hangisini
yaparsanız akademisyenlik
gönüllülük girişimcilik önemli değil
kendi madden oluşturun kendinizi tany
veev al aradakiler unutabilirsiniz Onlar
Ben maddeler ama kendiz veev al
ha
[Alkış]
ular